really punchy speech yesterday and you
said far too many conservatives in
england have forgotten that unionism is
in our party's dna
do you think that some of your
colleagues in westminster are just not
taking it seriously enough
well this was a wake-up call to the
party this was to remind everyone that
we are conservative
and unionists and the defeatism and
disinterest that i hear
too often sadly from colleagues from
members of the party
at south of the border is not helping
our fight up here because we are the
strongest
supporters for the union in scotland
we're the only ones that can stop the
snp
and put a break on their demands for
another independence referendum
to separate scotland but our message is
not being helped by those south of the
border
who somehow think this is a foregone
conclusion it's not we had a vote just
six years ago and two million scots
backed
scotland remaining part of the united
kingdom it's interesting
you talk about what people are saying
south of the border and in the speech
you also talk about
many including some who govern the
country want to see a uk government
focus on
england and you say that they're the
views of a small minority but i hear
them
far too often specifically what exactly
have you heard
well i think we've had a policy
and feeling amongst uk government
departments of devolving and forgetting
of passing on
barnet consequentials to scotland and
not looking at how that
benefits people right across the country
so i think it's to change that mindset
amongst government departments it sounds
like you're talking about specific
comments that you've heard from
other conservative mps it's it's an
attitude
it's a feeling that they pass on funding
significant funding through this covert
pandemic 6.5 billion pounds from the uk
government to the scottish government
and then they forget we need to do more
to remember that scotland has two
governments and the uk government and
the scottish government
should work together more to benefit
communities right across the country
so have you heard flipping comments
about the union from some of your
colleagues
well i'm not going to name colleagues
names i'm making this speech and it was
a stark speech it was to
make people look in the mirror and have
a long hard look at themselves to see
if they are doing enough to strengthen
the union have they done enough can they
do enough
should they do more and i think for a
number of people south of the border and
include the london media and the
commentary
who also seem to be writing this up as
if scotland it will somehow
become independent soon but they don't
look at the snp's record 13 years in
power here in scotland and our education
system
and standards are going backwards we
need to do far more to support our nhs
to get on top of crime to support the
local economy
because the national economy is
stagnating these are the issues we
should be focusing on
rather than working with a and for the
sepsis message to take scotland out of
the united kingdom
is boris johnson the man to save the
union
yes the prime minister is a strong
supporter of the united kingdom of the
union he believes that the
four nations of the united kingdom can
do far more together
than they can do separately on their own
but i think the prime minister would
also accept that his government and
successive governments
have not done enough to strengthen the
case for the union and that's why i made
my speech yesterday to put down this
marker to make sure everyone reflects on
what they have done and what they can do
to strengthen our four nations of the
united kingdom are his
approval ratings in scotland a problem
though
well approval ratings you know go up and
down and the future of our country a
300-year
economic political partnership well i
was just saying sophie
a 300-year political and economic
partnership that has served scotland
in the uk well doesn't rest on if one
individual is popular or not
this is about what our country means and
what we can do together united
as one nation working together
now i'm keen to talk to you about
margaret ferrier the
former snp mp who took that train from
glasgow to london
and then travelled back to glasgow after
receiving news that she tested positive
for covert 19. i mean how surprised
are you that she hasn't resigned yet i'm
surprised amazed and shocked that she
hasn't resigned she has
no credibility as a member of parliament
anymore people look to mps to set a
standard to follow the guidelines
that mps themselves have assisted in
making
and her actions were irresponsible they
were dangerous and they have endangered
many people she came into contact with
back to when she had symptoms over a
week ago to when she traveled to london
last monday knowing that she'd had a
test and then when she traveled on
public transport on a train from london
to glasgow
on tuesday having previously had a
positive test result for cover 19 the
night before
every element of that story has
endangered people right across the
country and she must stand down as a
member of parliament
now of course you resigned as a junior
minister when dominic cummings
broke the coronavirus rules
how damaging is it when people like
margaret ferrier when people like
dominic cummings as well
don't follow the same rules that
everyone else is supposed to
well i'm not here to support dominic
cummings i couldn't support him back in
may that's why i resigned my position
within the uk government but the case
with margaret ferrier
is extremely different and more serious
because she knowingly traveled
she got onto public transport with other
people on a five hour plus train journey
from london to glasgow knowing that she
was infectious knowing that she could
pass that virus on
to others she came into contact with a
virus we're still trying to get on top
of here in scotland and across the uk
that's still taking lives just this week
we've seen the highest daily death total
here in scotland for some time we are
still in the middle of this pandemic and
her actions
have endangered the safety of so many
people and i do have to question why
if nicola sturgeon thinks she's not fit
to be an mp anymore why does nicola
sturgeon think margaret ferrier
should still be in the snp still be a
member of that party
at the same time though talking about
the snp reaction nicholas sturgeon's
response to margaret farah has been
far far stronger than the conservative
response to dominic cummings she's been
stripped to the whip
nicholas sturgeon has spoke to her
saying she should stand down as an mp
you were the only person to actually
quit over dominic cummings do you think
in retrospect the conservatives should
have been much stronger
well i can only speak for my own actions
and i as you say quit the uk government
because i couldn't defend
what dominic cummings had done but i do
think there are questions on the
timeline here from the snp
when did they know about it did margaret
ferry or not tell a single colleague or
a single person in the snp
that she'd taken a test that she'd
tested positive that she'd traveled from
london to scotland with that positive
test
why did the commons authorities know
about it on wednesday afternoon
but the first minister and leader of the
snp didn't know about it until thursday
lunchtime
why did it take time for the whip to be
withdrawn they agreed a statement with
margaret ferrier and at the initial
stages they weren't withdrawing the whip
and as i say
nicola sturgeon believes margaret
ferrier shouldn't be a member of
parliament but she's not said
why she should continue as a member of
the scottish national party